i'm wondering if this is what do you
think is this going to be the
galvanizing issue that the left think
it's going to be you want to start well
first there are already republicans
talking about outlawing the pill as well
and many of these states will and even
whether they specifically outlaw the
pillar will still be a crime
uh we're we're not going back to 1973
we're going back to 1931 and before well
a lot of states my state of texas where
i grew up they have a law that was it
was not back to the 30s but michigan has
a law that goes back to the 30s texas
has one
automatically 30 days after roe versus
wade is repealed which will happen it'll
come out in june 30 days
an abortion in texas is a felony
no exception for rape no exception for
incest
life in prison for the doc that's texas
in texas well that's 30 million people
michigan has the same law no exception
for rape no exception for instance and
we know that most americans including
conservatives do not believe that
they're not on that page
they voted it in in texas not that long
ago and it's be because they're not
pro-life bill they're pro-life in prison
they want to punish they want to control
and and they're going to be able to now
well okay
go ahead i disagree i i don't think they
want to punish and control i look look i
am pro-choice
but here we we have a continuum right
somebody gets pregnant
and then there's birth and that whole
timeline in between
there should be a portion of that time
as there has been when an abortion is
legal whether it's medical the pill or
surgical
there's got to be a point at which we
say
this is a human being capable of living
outside the womb where maybe we don't we
don't do that i think that's what you
see a lot of in europe and a lot of
people are kind of settling around okay
15 weeks maybe now i have a good friend
lifelong liberal who happens to be
attached to a children's hospital in st
louis missouri
and he has seen preemies in incubators
five months along they they are born
they're there struggling to survive that
are now 20 year olds walking the planet
and he feels very this is a lifelong
liberal and he feels very strongly about
this that once that
baby
is viable why would you extinguish that
life now not everyone's going to agree
on this it's going to require some tough
work there are lots of questions you
just outlined what roe v wade holds and
what the supreme court is about to
overturn but that would be a demand that
won't ban abortions i realize there are
snap backwards
states have in louisiana past you
mentioned this to your monologue a
state assembly committee in louisiana
passed a bill yesterday seven to two
it's not a final law yet
that says life begins at fertilization
which means the iud is murder
this is what they're voting on in these
republican states if they had your kind
of sensible centrist position i don't
think people should be as upset but they
don't
right second largest state is going to
make it a felony of life and prison
yeah that's crazy
it is crazy right yeah and again just
the perspective most americans think
that's crazy
i would agree i think probably even in
texas yes they got it passed well i mean
we'll see if something we'll see in
november the texas legislature is on
about the michigan legislature right if
you all don't want
felony life and prison laws you can vote
them out right absolutely well another
thing i i learned this week that i i
think i maybe knew this but i forgot it
is that it didn't used to be a partisan
issue at the time roe versus wade but
passed but not a partisan issue
that it became a partisan issue because
of the christian right
they made it a partisan issue they made
it so that it became where the democrats
were for abortion being safe and legal
and republicans were also when their
mistresses got pregnant of course
[Applause]
you